[Music]
well today I want to talk about the
number two killer of Americans number
one of course is doctors let's look at
number two killer party bastards these
were talking about congestive heart
failure cardiopathy heart disease
coronary artery disease thrombotic
stroke from coronary thrombosis
pulmonary embolism deep vein thrombosis
spider veins varicose veins hemorrhoids
which are very close veins in a funny
place and aneurysms your up your head
they are all of these things are simple
nutritional deficiencies are the
exception of coronary heart disease
which is a combination of nutritional
deficiency and a inflammatory process
because people are eating too many
inflammatory foods we'll get into that
but the rest of all nutritional
deficiencies none of them have anything
to the genetics none of them have
anything to do with cholesterol okay so
let's look at congestive heart killer
congestive heart failure and of course
all these things are in the book
epigenetics to death at the genetic
disease transmission again the book
epigenetics the death of the genetic
series disease transmission and
congestive heart failure is a deficiency
have a single vitamin we've known that
for over 300 years goes back to 1740 to
and it was actually discovered by a
Japanese naval surgeon you take this one
extra vitamin on top of the 90 essential
nutrients you're gonna support promote
healthy cardiovascular physiology and
function and we've had people to run 27
prescription drugs these people been on
the heart-transplant list for three
years guess what their doctors after
just a week on the program took them off
at 27 per scripture drugs took them off
the heart transplant list and declared
them cured now cardiomyopathy heart
disease is it cause of a sudden heart
death in athletes and people do um hard
physical work they want you to blame
that on genetics but that's your disease
cardiomyopathy heart disease
hypertrophic cardiomyopathy of heart
disease is a simple efficiency of a
single mineral I'm the only guy who's
ever done 1,700 autopsies and human
beings that have died of a party mafia
heart disease efficiency of a single
mineral and it's published in both
English
and the US scientific journals and
Chinese and Mandarin and Cantonese
Chinese scientific journals and there's
1,700
it's a deficiency of a single mineral in
pigs is called pretty much the heart
disease and humans and pigs is called
mulberry heart disease caused by the
same mineral deficiency artery artery
disease is caused by a reduced intake of
antioxidants to protect your arteries
from inflammation things like vitamin C
vitamin E flavonoids those sorts of
things and then of course the
inflammation piece which comes from and
I said this in 1971 and it's just now
being sort of 50 years later being said
by others as a inflammatory disease
eating fried foods processed meats oils
things like gluten wheat brother and
oats thrombosis now this one may eat
lawsuits genesee FDA federal court which
I prevailed Trumbo this corner is from
BOCES where you get a coronary artery
blocked by a blood clot traumatic stroke
or you get a brain artery clogged by a
blood clot pulmonary embolism and then
of course deep vein thrombosis these are
all caused by a deficiency and over two
pistons here omega-3 essential fatty
acids or a ratio between omega-3 sixes
and nines no spider veins varicose veins
hemorrhoids which are again varicose
veins at a funny place and aneurysms
those hurtful
previous diseases and our chilled Izzy's
aneurysms rather than your brain your
heart or aorta or pulmonary artery or
iliac arteries femoral arteries are just
simple deficiencies of a single mineral
okay and these are easily reversed
easily prevented all these diseases are
easily prevented they have nothing to do
genetic so you had everybody here family
died of cardiovascular disease guess
what you get the book epigenetics
contact or young give you associate and
say hey I need the healthy brain and
heart Peck I want to reduce my risk of
closure disease and when you see your
hair color coming back you have white
gray or silver hair you see your hair
color coming back is here spider veins
your varicose veins and hemorrhoids sort
of reducing in size just oh my gosh
guess what
my blood vessels microvascular system is
healing on the inside in case you can
have these external signals that things
are good or going on on the inside
because the healthy brain and heart pack
is designed to support and promote
healthy maintenance repair of the heart
arteries veins capillaries and anything
to do with the cardiovascular system ok
epigenetics the death of the snake
disease transmission
now this research is based on billions
of dollars research in the livestock and
pet industry this is not something I'm
making up and hoping and praying that's
true
this is drop dead predictable okay this
is where these nutrients these minerals
and these vitamins were proven to be
essential nutrients by producing and
reversing and preventing these diseases
so there's no doubt about it
and of course cardiologists make their
living by treating you for these things
rather than preventing and get rid of so
if you're smart like you think you
aren't quiz your listen to this program
what you want to do is contact your
young TV associate and get the book
epigenetics the death of the genetic
series disease transmission you look up
you get the Parkdale you're cutting up
these heart disease coronary artery
disease from both the spider veins
varicose vein hemorrhoids and aneurysms
you'll be amazed what you can do to
reduce your risk anything bet that
reverse them raising